You're not going to believe this,
but we have to talk about the regressive
left today.
I've actually been trying to get away
from discussing the regressive left
lately and instead talk about the ideas
of classical liberalism,
which I believe in,
but current events keep dragging me
back.
I see on social media that people are
using the phrase regressive left a bit
less lately and replacing it with terms
like big tier.
The control left or the illiberal left,
whatever name you use for this well
meaning yet painfully misguided set of
ideas is largely irrelevant.
We needed this phrase to identify this
backwards ideology which puts groups
before people and sometimes you need a
label to get people to understand that
an idea,
the portion of the left,
which is no longer progressive meaning
for progress but regressive meaning
going backwards has been identified and
now we're clearly bringing people to the
side of reason.
All of you who talk about this with
friends and family who used the
regressive left Hashtag on twitter and
share these videos are part of this
political awakening.
Yes.
It seems like these backwards ideas are
getting stronger in some circles,
but at the same time,
finally,
for the first time in a long time,
those of us who are liberal and open to
new ideas are coming together and being
heard.
Whether or not you like trump,
his wind was a huge rejection of the
identity politics of the left.
But don't take my word for that.
Bernie Sanders said it himself.
The only thing which can replace the
regressive descent of the left is a
return to true liberalism or liberalism,
which defends free speech and
expression,
uh,
liberalism.
That is for liberty and rights of the
individual and most importantly,
a liberalism that is one for human
liberty.
I now believe that this regressive
ideology is the biggest threat to
freedom in western civilization that
exists today with the rise of trump and
the constant comparisons they make of
him to Hitler.
The left now has the perfect boogeyman
to use to excuse anything.
If your opponent is a vile racist,
then you can use violence in any means
necessary to stop him.
The regressive left has already begun.
Using violence is a tactic and I fear
that that's just getting started.
If you're only now getting up to speed
on what the regressive left is,
allow me to recap quickly the regressive
control,
the liberal left,
whatever you want to call it,
is a group of people who place identity
usually based on immutable
characteristics in a pecking order of
social importance such as race,
gender,
and religion were victim.
Hood is the highest virtue to be had.
This oppression.
Olympics allows groups to compete for
who is the most oppressed,
thus the most virtuous.
And if someone isn't as oppressed as
you,
then you have full authority to oppress
them accordingly.
So black lives matter can protesting
gain rights.
March in Toronto,
white men can be banned from leading
lgbt organizations on college campuses,
prolife women that can be kicked out of
women's rights marches and so on.
This backwards ideology which demands we
judge each other,
not on the content of our character,
but on the color of our skin or some
other baked in trait puts the collective
ahead of the individual.
It loves all of its minority groups to
behave as monoliths.
So if you're a true individual,
meaning you don't subscribe to the ideas
that the group think has attributed to
you based on those immutable
characteristics,
you must be cast out.
Many of the guests on my show have
suffered from this backwards backlash.
I on Hirsi,
Ali [inaudible],
Sarah Haider and Ali Rizvi,
all the felt abandoned by the left
because they speak out about the
problems within Islam.
They dare to fight for a more tolerant,
more truly progressive Islam in tune
with the modern society and basic
liberal values and for that they're
labeled bigots or worse,
the southern poverty law center even
labeled Majid as an anti Muslim
extremists.
In reality,
madge is a former Islamist who has
devoted his life to try to reform Islam
from the inside to try to reconcile his
faith with the modern world fighting for
gays and atheists and women and any
other free thinkers living under
theocratic rule.
For this,
he is called a porch monkey and other
vile names by supposed progressive's
while at the same time he's admired by
many on the right for being outspoken.
This is the absolute height of
absurdity,
but it all makes sense.
When you value groups over individuals,
the individual must be sacrificed at the
altar of the collective,
so when any of these people dare speak
out and call for true tolerance,
they find their tolerance met with
intolerance,
the left gloves,
diversity and skin color.
Just not diversity in thought.
Of course,
this regressive ideology isn't just tied
to Islam at all.
My guest this week is Larry Elder,
a black conservative who has had every
label and smear thrown at him.
Again,
like with the previous guests I just
mentioned,
these slurs come from people on the left
who would rather silence and dismiss
their opponents then actually engage
them in an honest way.
People often ask me which interview I've
done.
That's changed my views the most and I
almost always say that it was the first
time I sat down with Larry Elder.
He challenged my views on systemic
racism as well as the need for a strong
family and was one of the people that
helped sell me on why small government
is important.
If you haven't seen the video,
we'll post the link right down below.
Larry challenged me and I wasn't ready
so I can't say that it was my best
moment on camera,
but I listened and learned and just as
importantly we didn't edit any of it out
so I'm looking forward to picking up
where Larry and I left off and as for
where we left off,
this is where I feel there might be
nothing left for me on the modern
American left.
You all know most of my positions on
important issues.
I'm for free speech,
even for White Supremacist,
Richard Spencer to speak and not get
punched in the face has happened just a
couple of days ago and I'm still a card
carrying liberal.
By the way,
I'm for gay marriage.
I'm pro choice,
I'm pro legalization of marijuana.
I'm against the death penalty and the
list goes on.
At the same time though,
I'm against this oppression Olympics.
I'm against safe spaces and trigger
warnings.
I'm against labeling all my opponents,
bigots and racists and I'm against d
platforming speakers,
especially at colleges where ideas are
meant to be challenged and debated.
I'm also for states' rights for
following the constitution and most
importantly for having a limited
government that gets out of the way so
that you can live your life to the
fullest.
I've said a few times on the show that
defending my liberal principles has
become a conservative position.
Interestingly,
I've also heard conservatives like
Andrew Klavan and Dennis prager say that
they are conservatives because they
really are liberals.
This is where we might get lost in the
definition of liberal in the modern
sense for his classical liberals.
So if you're still confused about that,
check out a video I did a couple of
weeks ago called why I'm a liberal.
We'll put a link to it right down below.
The point is that if the issues I care
about most free speech rights of the
individual and limited government
designed to maximize liberty now have
almost nothing to do with the modern
left.
My position is basically haven't
changed,
but I've watched as my team has gone off
the deep end.
The Battle of ideas always gets to a
tipping point and I sense that we're
closing in on one right now.
If we can't reign in this madness on the
left than Donald Trump will be all too
happy to show them his authoritarian
side.
Both sides are ramping up for a
showdown.
That seems incredibly obvious to me.
So while I absolutely believe that the
new center filled with liberals,
conservatives,
and Libertarians and others is rapidly
growing,
maybe I've lost the left and maybe
that's okay.
But to end this direct message,
I now kick this back to you guys.
If you're liberal,
is there anything left for you on the
left or are you left out?
Is it now the conservative position to
truly be liberal?
Let me know in the comments right down
below and we'll see if there's anything
left to discuss.
Joining me this week is an author,
a television pundit host of a nationally
syndicated radio show,
and now most importantly a returning
guests in that very chair,
Larry elder.
Welcome back to the Ruben report.
Dave,
thank you for having me.
I appreciate it.
Well,
I am looking forward to this because I
mentioned at the top of the show that I
don't know that any guests that I've
ever had on challenged me directly as
much as you did and actually managed to
change some of my feelings.
That's gotta feel pretty good for you.
Well,
I had a lot of good feedback from the
interview and people compliment me,
but I said the economist would go to you
because you were asking questions and
unlike a lot of interviewers,
you really cared about the answer.
Listen,
then you responded.
And so I think if we made the interview
so great.
So for you to sit down with a liberal,
and I think last time we literally
didn't know each other.
I think maybe we had met for 10 seconds
before he sat in the chair.
You sit down with the liberal and I
think that you were ready to go.
So when I said something about systemic
reasons,
like you were ready to pounce and you
did.
And I,
and my guy said to me after we had only
been doing the show for a few months,
do you know,
do you want to edit that part out?
Because there's a part where you really
kind of catch me in like a a moment
where I don't know and we'll link to it
right down below.
I want people to see this.
I think it's important.
Um,
how hard is it for you to sit down with
liberals generally speaking and,
and have an honest conversation?
Depends on the liberal.
If it's an open minded liberal who
really cares about what you have to say
it,
it's pretty easy.
Uh,
if it isn't,
if it's somebody who,
who's already decided what they've
decided and believe that liberals,
the Conservatives are mean people,
rotten people,
cold people,
anti science people,
they were going to be in for a bumpy
night.
Right.
Okay.
So let's,
uh,
I want to just recap a couple of the
things we talked about last time for
people that haven't seen it and then
we'll get to all the new stuff.
So real quick,
just tell me a little bit about your
political evolution.
How do you end up here as a
conservative?
Well,
it wasn't so much an evolution as it was
kind of like,
uh,
a series of things that happened to me.
People I've met,
books that I've read,
and that all together you added up.
And I ended up being a conservative.
My father was always a republican.
Uh,
my mom,
uh,
Democrat and so at the kitchen table,
they would fight all the time about
politics.
And when I was younger,
I sided with my mom.
I think partially because it was just my
mom.
And when I got older,
I began to side with my father much to
my mother's a consternation.
So going back that,
let's say 58 years roughly,
uh,
what is,
what are the types of things that your
dad was fighting for as a Republican at
that time?
I remember vividly during,
during a a Watergate,
my dad was defending Richard Nixon,
which I thought was indefensible.
I thought would Richard Nixon was
accused of doing with Sabrina suborning
perjury and getting other people to lie,
uh,
was,
was deeply wrong.
My Dad thought it was trivial.
My Dad felt that Richard Nixon had not
done anything to enrich himself,
that national security was not
jeopardize.
Nobody died.
Why would you impeach a president over
the fact that he was trying to cover up
a break in to the Watergate?
That was my dad's position.
My mom physician of course,
was that Richard Nixon was a crook and a
liar.
Fast forward,
the polls show that most Americans now
believe that Richard Nixon should not
have resigned over what he did and feel
that what Hillary did was far worse and
she did not have to resign.
Yeah.
What does that say about you?
Sorta how,
where we've come and where we were,
that we're so obsessed with scandal
right now and when we know right now
trump's been in office for,
as we're taping this like five days or
something and it's like there is just
going to be massive scandal after
massive scandal.
Obama said just a couple weeks ago that
he's very proud that his administration
got through without a major scandal.
Now,
that depends on where you're definitely,
I suspect you disagree with that,
but in terms of like a personal scandal
or some real feeling of something or
that kind of thing,
but,
but maybe you don't see it that way.
I do not see it that way.
But your question was,
what does it say about us?
Where are we gone?
Yeah.
It says about us is that when it's
Republican in office,
somebody like Richard Nixon that people
did not like,
there's one level of scrutiny and one
level of judgment.
And when it's,
when it's,
when it's a Democrat,
somebody like Clinton or like Obama,
there's a whole different thing for
Obama to say with a straight face that
I've not had a major scandal.
Are you kidding me?
What was fast and furious?
What was Hillary's email server?
What was the denying the nonprofit
applications of,
uh,
of conservatives with the,
with the irs a what's,
you can have your doctor,
you can keep your doctor.
Um,
and Obama reiterated that line after it
was obvious from the,
from the rigs that you couldn't
necessarily keep your doctor or you
couldn't necessarily keep your plan.
So I buy the line,
didn't he basically say that the ends
justify the means?
That's sort of what he's saying.
Like I had to sell it and we kind of
knew I'm not defending that that
particular leg,
but that was sort of his may a cold.
I still think as a scandal for you to
say that you're going to bend the cost
curve down,
people are going to be no worse off.
They're going to save money and you
don't save the money.
Uh,
when you know for well that you can't
keep your doctor if you want to keep
your doctor and they say it anyway.
That to me as far as I'm concerned,
is a scandal pulling out all the troops
out of Iraq over the advice of his
entire national security team.
Hilary wanted him to keep a stay behind
force.
His Secretary of defense wanted to stay
behind forest.
The CIA director wanted to stay behind
for the joint chiefs,
wanted to stay behind,
force our,
our US ambassador to Iraq advised Obama
against pulling all the troops out.
He did it anyway and the media gave him
a path for that.
And uh,
Ray Odierno,
the um,
we tiring army general of the joint
chiefs said that had the troops not been
pulled out,
isis could have been dealt with.
That to me is a massive scandal for
which Obama got a pass and still gets a
pass.
So is that one of the situations where
we're damned if we do and we're damned
if we don't?
So that had he stayed at most people,
and I'm guessing you included,
probably didn't want us to be there
forever having left the way he did,
they were having democratic elections
right before that.
I mean literally in the months before we
left,
they were having their first free
democratic elections and now,
now it's an absolute disaster.
So is that just one of those situations?
There was no win in a way for him at the
end.
Cause either we're going to occupy them
forever or we're going to pull out and
then some bad stuff's gonna happen,
which is exactly what happened.
Okay.
Now,
now we're talking about kind of the
merits of the Iraq war and,
and whether or not we should have stayed
or not stayed.
And,
and that's fine.
Um,
look,
I,
I believe that as long as the American
public does not have the will to stick
it through,
because what George W.
Bush said was,
we'll leave when a rack can stand up.
As long as the American people did not
have the will to do that,
we shouldn't have gone.
Uh,
but I'm surprised,
I think,
uh,
George W.
Bush and surprising Dick Cheney is
surprised that over the advice of all
the people that I just now mentioned,
Obama pulled all the troops out anyway.
He envisioned a stay behind force,
uh,
to make sure that Iraq would be stable.
I mean,
we stayed in,
um,
in,
in Germany,
we stayed in Japan.
We're still in South Korea.
Yeah.
It takes a while for doing shirts.
We have 30,000
troops in Germany now or something like
that.
Nothing like that.
It takes a while for it,
for democracy to take route.
Uh,
and for us to bail out the way we did
was,
was incredible.
You're responsible and I,
and I thought jeopardize national
security.
And again,
I am surprised that Obama felt confident
enough to walk into the Oval Office,
uh,
and,
and ignore the advice of all these
people.
So would your argument be basically that
these,
these scandals,
these issues that you brought up,
basically he got a pass because the
media is sort of in on it with the
Democrats?
Is that the basic idea?
Absolutely.
For him to say,
as he said many times during press
conferences,
I most proud of the fact that I rescued
the u s economy.
Really the major things that were done,
tarp and bailing out the auto companies.
George W.
Bush had set that into motion.
Uh,
his stimulus program.
Most economists don't believe it did
anything.
Obamacare was a brand new entitlement
dropped on the back of the,
of job creators.
Uh,
and,
and notice how he no longer bragged
about things like a cash for clunkers
and cash for clunkers.
He doesn't even,
uh,
cash for clunkers rather,
it didn't talk about that anymore
because they were boondoggles they did
not work.
The cost,
the American people,
American taxpayers money.
Okay.
So I know that a certain amount of
people are gonna hear what you said
there and go,
that doesn't make any sense.
And then the other hand,
there's going to be a very 50 50 split
on sort of where,
where people are at before this.
So let's move to some of the
philosophical stuff,
which I think is okay,
where are we can get into the real meat
of this,
right?
So racism,
this is the issue that more people
contacted me about when I was discussing
you than anything else.
And it's where you challenged me the
most on systemic racism.
So first off,
what does any racism exist in America?
Not Systemic racism.
We'll get to that in a sec,
but what racism is real,
right?
We live in a country has got 330 million
people,
roughly eight to 10% of them believe
Elvis is still alive.
Almost half of them belief.
If you've seen elvis a letter,
you'll get it.
Obviously there's racism.
There are individuals who don't like
other people because of their race.
No question about it.
But are there corporations,
they have a policy of not hiring
anybody?
Uh,
are there governmental agencies?
They have a policy of not hiring
anybody?
Uh,
the answer is no.
If you can tell me the company,
IBM apple that has a policy of not
hiring black people tell me or brown
people tell me who that company is and
we can deal with it.
I don't know what people mean when they
talk about institutional racism.
If this were the 50s,
I would know what you're talking about.
Uh,
when there was,
when there was a segregation that was
legal segregation in the south where you
couldn't marry somebody,
uh,
outside your race in certain states,
but that is no longer the case right
now.
The racism that people talk about right
now,
in my opinion,
is individual stuff where some
individual doesn't like you or some
individuals don't like you.
But is it something that is anything
akin to what we experienced in the
fifties and sixties absolutely not.
And I think it's insulting to people who
have fought hard and died in the 50s and
the 60s to get us to this point to act
like things are just the same when you
have people like Eric holder's saying as
he did when he was age,
we now have pernicious racism,
which he said was every bit as bad as
the old racism.
What the hell are you talking about?
I mean it's,
it's insulting to me.
So what do you do to defeat that idea?
So again,
this is you,
you mentioned that in our conversation
and it really did,
you know,
you got me,
I said,
well,
there's systemic racism.
And you said,
well,
what companies can I just,
I just asked you for an example.
You got me.
And so I do agree with you.
There are racist people.
There are certain amount of people that
don't like black people that don't like
you cause they don't like gays,
etc.
We live in a free country.
You allowed to not like people,
maybe odious and an unpleasant,
but you're allowed to.
You can't harm them,
but correct.
But what do you do to stop the idea of
what you're talking about?
That things have changed for the better
and that there's a certain amount of
people that want that oppression,
that want the impression because it,
it sort of puts them above other people.
How do you fight that?
You've been trying to fight it,
I think for a long time.
Tell the truth.
That's how you find it.
I mean org,
this movement called black lives matter.
I think we talked about that a little
bit.
Um,
it's,
it says bogus and his phone or your
movement as the notion that Oj Simpson
is innocence from having killed two
people.
Uh,
it's a fraud.
Um,
most cops simply want to do a good job
and come home.
Most cops frankly,
are more hesitant to pull the trigger
against a black suspect than a white
suspect.
There've been a couple of studies that
have shown that recently.
One of them was uh,
uh,
an economist from Harvard named Roland
Fryer and he is apparently the youngest
tenured professor in the history of
Harvard.
Uh,
and he's a tenured professor in the
Department of Economics and he did a
study to find out about police
brutality.
He assumed he would find the opposite
and he was shocked.
He said when he found out that most
police officers,
uh,
are,
are more reluctant to use deadly force
on a black suspect than a non black
suspect.
And the reason in my opinion is pretty
obvious.
If you shoot a black person and there's
any question whatsoever about it,
you're going to be under the gun,
you're going to be po,
possibly prosecute it,
maybe lose your pension,
maybe go to jail.
Um,
coughs are definitely afraid of being
perceived as engaging in racial
profiling.
There was a recent poll that just came
out and it turns out 75% of cops say
that they are more reluctant now to
engage with citizens,
uh,
then,
then before,
before the black lives matter movement.
Yeah.
So what's the disconnect then when you,
when you see these,
uh,
cities,
when you see Atlanta and you see Chicago
and you see Ferguson and all of these
places that are usually under democratic
control,
they usually have democratic mayors.
The group think would tell you,
wait a minute.
Democrats are,
are helping black people.
So where is the disconnect coming from?
A lot of people are not thinking
critically,
Dave,
they're just not,
uh,
take,
take Baltimore.
Baltimore was run by a black mayor.
She got 85% of the vote.
What kind of politician gets 85% of the
vote?
I think Kadafi got 105% and the top two
officials running the police department
were black.
The command staff,
majority black.
Um,
all the city council,
Democrat,
majority black,
the state attorney,
the one who brought the charges against
the six officers,
uh,
is a black female.
And yet,
and still they are still talking about
systemic racism.
Um,
the fact of the matter is a lot of black
suspects or engaging in bad conduct and
the police are doing their job and often
the bad conduct is against another black
victim.
Yeah.
Does this all come down to education for
you?
Because at the end of the day,
if you can teach people properly about
history and if you can teach them
properly about what the role of
government is and all of those things,
that that's really how you untie this
stuff from just the screeching people on
both sides.
I think so.
And but,
but it's also all about,
uh,
rationally connect connecting the dots.
Is it really true that a,
that a young black man is more likely to
be pulled over by a cop than a young
white man?
Uh,
and if it is true,
the other question is why.
Um,
and you cannot have a meaningful
discussion about any of this without
talking about behavior.
I think maybe the last time we were
here,
we talked about a national institutes of
justice study.
Uh,
that's the research arm of the DOJ.
they did a study that came out in 2013
called traffic stops and race,
and it turns out that whether you're
talking about driving without a license
or driving while drunk or driving a with
a busted tail pipe or driving without a
seatbelt or driving without a car seat
in the back,
uh,
it turns out black motorists were more
likely to commit those crimes.
Then a white motorist,
uh,
and the study said that the differences
in stopping have to do with differences
in offending.
If you can't have a meaningful
discussion,
unless you have a meaningful discussion
about behavior right now,
I suspect that some people on the left
would hear that and they'd say,
well,
black people have been oppressed
economically,
so they are more likely to have a tail
light out or some other thing you,
you would just say that's nonsense.
You would just say that individual
responsibility,
you've got to drive a car that's
supposed to be the one that's on.
That's right.
Also,
there's more poor white people in the
country than there are poor black
people.
But if black people that complained
about being disproportionately pulled
over,
um,
half of all the homicides in this
country involved black victims,
almost all of the black victims were
killed by other black people.
Um,
I don't know what Ha,
what that has to do with coffee being
racist.
It has to do with the fact that it
disproportionately large percentage of
crime is committed by a law.
A small percentage of people,
usually males,
usually young black males,
often against their peers.
And that is because of the lack of
fathers in the home.
I didn't say it,
Obama said it.
A kid raised without a father is five
times more likely to be poor,
uh,
nine times more likely to drop out of
school in 20 times more likely to end up
in jail.
The number one problem facing this
country is not a bad cops.
Uh,
not Obama care.
It is the large number of,
of,
of children raised without fathers.
That is a product of the welfare state
between 1890 and 1920,
1930.
Believe it or not,
a black kid was slightly more likely to
be born to mothers and fathers married
to each other than a white kid.
So what's the connection there?
What's the 1920 connections to the
welfare state starts and why does that
harm the black family?
More?
Uh,
the welfare state,
uh,
really got kicked off in the mid
sixties.
25% of black kids are born outside of
wedlock in 1960 right now it's 73%.
And what happened is literally Lyndon
Johnson launched a so called war on
poverty and he sent a workers literally
knocking on people's doors to a prize.
Women of their right to welfare provided
there was no man in the house.
And so what we've done is changed the
culture.
Uh,
we've incentivize women to marry the
government.
We've allowed men to abandon their
financial and more responsibility.
It is a neutron bomb dropped on this
country,
uh,
all because of the war on poverty that
was done by Lyndon Johnson and the
Democrats and with,
with the tacit support by Republicans as
well.
One quick thing and we know what we know
that there is a,
that there is a negative incentive
because in 1996,
when Bill Clinton signed the welfare
reform act of 1996,
welfare declined by over 50%,
far steeper than anybody predicted.
It turned out there was a bunch of able
bodied people enable minded people
sitting on couches and when the,
when the,
uh,
when the Jig was up they got off the
couch and got it and got to work.
Yeah.
Do you think the intentions are good?
So we John and was,
pushes this when the Democrats and the
Republicans are going to work where
their intentions were going to help
people get out of my way or is there
really something more nefarious going?
No,
the intentions were quite good.
Uh,
uh,
Fdr talked about,
the corrosive effect of,
of government dependency when he
launched the new deal.
Uh,
and,
uh,
Lyndon Johnson talked about getting
people off of government dependencies
and making them more self self
sufficient by launching the war on
poverty.
Those were their stated goals and I
believed them.
Uh,
but human nature is such that if you
allow somebody in easy out,
some people will take an easy out.
And that's what we've done with a lot of
people.
So basically we've said to a certain
subset of people and it I guess is a
disproportionate amount of black people.
We've said you can get a certain amount
of government handouts and basically
your argument is that this is now just
leaving people in the status quo.
Because if you can get something
subsidized housing,
whatever it is,
food stamps and you don't have to do
anything and you'll just take it,
that's not a black characteristic.
That's a characteristic of what else,
what any human of human nature.
And uh,
there was uh,
uh,
a poll taken in 1986 by the La Times.
They asked poor people in non poor
people a bunch of questions.
Um,
and one of them was,
do you believe that that poor people
have additional children to get
additional money from welfare?
The majority of non poor people said no.
They probably thought that it was
insulting if not racist.
64% of poor people said yes.
Also,
they were asked this question,
poor people,
where do you believe that welfare is a
crutch,
a creates dependency or do you believe
it's a,
a,
a means to get you to stand on your own
two feet and go forward?
More of them said it was a crutch that
created dependency than it was a means
to get you on your own two feet and go
forward.
These are poor people responding to this
poll.
Yeah.
So basically guilt has a lot to do with
this.
The guilt sort of white liberal guilt in
a way has actually subjected black
people to,
uh,
not all black people of course,
but a certain subset of poor black
people to a set of circumstances that
they almost can't get out of.
I think that's part of it.
But also I think part of it is people
that are comfortable and wealthy and
well educated look around to figure out
how they can perfect the world.
Uh,
and they forget that part of getting
anywhere is overcoming obstacles and,
and struggling.
Uh,
and if you make things real comfortable
for people,
some people are going to take the easy
way out.
So I think it's a kind of mindset,
that kind of mentality.
Yeah.
When did we get to that point where
fighting for what's yours fighting that
no one should give you anything,
that the government isn't supposed to
give you anything and no one should,
that it is your life to live.
It is your,
it's your job as a human to pursue what
makes you happy and take what you can.
And that doesn't mean destroying
everything around you.
Right.
But,
but finding what makes you happy.
When did that get crossed up?
Is it all connected to this,
do you think that's,
that's a good question.
Uh,
I think the founding fathers intended
for us to have what people have
characterized as rugged individualism.
Article One,
section eight of the constitution,
uh,
set forth a handful of things that the
federal government should do.
Uh,
they did not include social security.
They did not include Medicare.
They did not include Medicaid.
They did not include charity.
But we've gotten away from that,
I think,
because as people become more and more
affluent,
um,
they look around and try to perfect the
world.
Would you roll back all of those things?
I know.
Do you consider yourself a libertarian?
You're basically a libertarian.
Yes.
So,
so you wouldn't lay a libertarian small,
I'm a law and order a libertarian.
So you think there should be driver's
licenses?
Oh,
of course.
Yeah.
So you're not like,
well,
because that's an important distinction
to make because there are plenty of
libertarians that don't.
So you're,
so what makes you not a classical
liberal then?
Because that's,
this is become one of the themes over
the last time.
I am a classical liberal and the John
Stuart mill sense of it.
Yeah,
absolutely.
I am somebody who believes in maximum
personal freedom,
but also you have to believe in the
excellent personal responsibility.
And that is to deal with the
consequences of your choices.
Uh,
and,
and a lot of people don't want to do
that.
Uh,
they want to show people from,
uh,
the,
the vestiges of,
of,
of the world of life.
Uh,
and when you do that,
you also will create some other kind of
reaction that there'll be worse.
My father used to say,
when you're trying to get something for
nothing,
you often end up getting nothing for
something.
Yeah.
So what sort of social safety net should
there be then?
Or do you not think that there should
be?
And this may be the difference between a
small l libertarian and a classical
liberal?
Uh,
I think most classical liberals would
feel the way I feel.
And that is that the safety net should
be provided by other individuals,
not by government,
but by churches,
nonprofits.
One of the things that I'm Alexis de
Tocqueville wrote about in democracy in
America,
where were all of these,
what were called mutual aid societies
that were set up.
This is before social security,
before Medicare,
before Medicaid.
Uh,
and believe it or not,
um,
a black person living in Chicago in
1920s,
1930s,
was more likely to have health care
insurance and a white person because,
uh,
he joined these mutual aid societies
that provided that.
All right.
So let's circle back to the family stuff
because I remember you said the family
stuff last time and the importance of a
two parent family.
I was,
I come,
my parents were still married 40 some
odd years.
I just went back to my childhood home in
New York and for the first time I did
have,
I think I saw a little more tangibly
what you were talking about,
to go to my parents' house to feel that
it was the same place that I grew up in
that same community that I was part of.
I visited family friends and some
relatives that were nearby and it did
feel like it connected me to something
that was important.
It's sort of an a femoral thing.
It's something that's not quite
tangible,
but something that's important that
does.
It lays your roots,
so to speak,
and that you can sort of figure out who
you are from that.
Is that really what you're talking about
with the family?
That not,
it's not just that there's a
breadwinner,
but something else,
something that's sort of bigger than
that that really can lay out what a life
is supposed to be.
Absolutely.
It's not just a additional check as you
pointed out.
It's also being a role model.
Watching your father get up,
go,
go to work when he doesn't feel like it.
Watching him live up to his
responsibilities.
And you know,
the,
the three arguably the biggest leaders
in this country,
black leaders in this country or Jesse
Jackson,
Al Sharpton and Louis Farrakhan and all
of them had difficult not for you,
Huh?
All of them had difficult if not
nonexistent relationship with their own
fathers.
Jesse Jackson's mother was a teenager,
uh,
who was impregnated by the married man
who lived next door.
And when Jesse Jackson was raised in
South Carolina,
kits taunted him.
Jesse ain't got no daddy.
Jesse ain't got no daddy because that's
how rare it was in those days to be
raised without a father.
Al Sharpton had a nice middle class life
until his father abandoned the family
and then down to the ghetto.
And in the case of Farah Khan,
his mom was a strange from her husband,
had a boyfriend,
took back up with the husband,
got pregnant,
didn't want the boyfriend to know and
tried to abort,
uh,
Louis Farrakhan with a coat hanger.
So all three of these men in my opinion
have deep psychological issues because
of the lack of relationship with their
own fathers.
And that is one of the reasons why,
in my opinion,
they're so angry despite the fact that
things have gotten so much better in
terms of race relations in this country.
So basically they can't let go of that
pain.
I mean,
not to fully cycle analyze them,
but they're dealing with a personal pain
that is extremely painful for sure.
And they can't let go of that pain.
So now they're kind of projecting it on
to the rest of us via policy,
in my opinion.
Again,
I'm not a psychologist if I were,
that's what I would say.
Um,
now a lot of people have had bad
circumstances and have not been that,
uh,
that sour because of it.
My father.
And then we talked about him before.
My father does not know who his
biological father is.
The man named elder was a man who was in
his life the longest.
He was a alcoholic who abused him and
abused,
uh,
his mother physically.
Uh,
and my dad was literally thrown out of
the house when he was 13 years old by
his mother's then boyfriend who sided
with,
uh,
her boyfriend when he and my dad got
into a corner when he was 13 years old,
came home from chemo from school,
and he was making too much noise to
boyfriend.
Got Mad.
My Dad said something to him,
uh,
his mother's side with the boyfriend out
of the house.
He goes,
wow.
13 years old,
Jim Crow,
south Athens,
Georgia,
right at the beginning of the Great
Depression.
My father was never angry though my
father said to us,
always us,
meaning my two brothers and me,
I picked up the cars.
I dealt with them to the best that I
could.
Uh,
what did he do?
Did you do a series of whatever anybody
would pay him to do a cleaning?
This cleaning that ultimately he got a
job with the pullman porters.
They were the largest private employer
of blacks in those days,
and he was able to travel,
travel around the country.
That's how we ended up in California.
He came here one time,
it was sunny,
people smiled,
it seemed more friendly.
And after the war was over at my dad,
uh,
I relocated to California to try and get
a job as a cook.
And he was told that he had no
references,
which was California's way of saying we
don't hire black people.
Right.
Uh,
and my dad ended up being a janitor,
worked two full time jobs at the
janitor,
save these nickels and dimes,
started a little cafe near the Pico
Union area,
which he ran until the 80s.
In fact,
I wrote about this in my last book is
called Dear Father,
dear son,
two lives eight hours because my father
and I did not get along.
Uh,
I thought of my father is grouchy and an
honoree and I couldn't understand why he
was so ill tempered until I got 25 years
old.
We stopped talking to each other when I
was 15 we didn't speak to each other for
10 years.
Wow.
And my dad and I sat down for what I
thought would be a 10 minute
conversation.
It ended up being an eight hour
conversation and that's why I wrote the
book a dear father,
dear son,
two lives,
eight hours about this conversation.
Do you think that despite what you've
said about,
uh,
President Obama,
do you think that now that he's out of
office,
maybe he could step into the role that
you'd like to see him in?
So instead of America turning to Jesse
Jackson and Farrakhan and Sharpton,
maybe they can turn it to you,
but if not to Larry elder,
that may be Obama when you disconnected
from politics,
can actually talk about some of those
things.
Cause I mean,
you addressed it a second ago,
you said he did mention the family and
mentioned fathers and all that.
So is there a chance that you think
there's a chance for that?
I'm not optimistic because,
uh,
in his last press conference he talked
about we still have a great deal to do
on race.
By the way,
when people talk about a great deal to
do on race or all they really mean is
how black people feel about white people
and vice versa.
They don't care about Hispanic,
they don't care about Asians.
They really care about the relationship
between blacks and whites.
Um,
and Obama has throughout his eight
years,
in my opinion,
when he could have ignored the race card
or put it in perspective,
picked it up,
uh,
whether it's Cambridge police or whether
it's,
uh,
trayvon Martin.
If I had a Sony would look like Trayvon,
whether it's invoking ferguson,
whether it's hiring somebody like Eric
Holder lecturing in the country on race
and racism.
Uh,
Obama I think,
believes that racism remains this huge,
massive problem in America despite his
election and despite his reelection.
And I don't,
and so I don't think he's going to say
the right thing and do the right thing.
I think he,
I think he's encouraged black people to
think of themselves as victims as
opposed to saying,
look at me.
I busted my bud.
My parents made sure I had a good
education.
I didn't make bad moral mistakes.
Uh,
I got married before I had kids follow
my model and you'll be fine.
He has not said that at all.
What he said is,
we have real problems in this country.
He embraced the black lives matter
movement.
Uh,
I mentioned Trayvon Martin.
I mentioned some of the other things.
In my opinion,
the reason that a lot of people voted
for Obama was because he,
they thought he was going to do exactly
what you suggested,
which is to heal us,
put things in perspective,
tell young black people they ought not
be angry when they're pulled over by a
cop.
All the copies is doing is his job.
Instead,
he did the opposite.
So I'm not optimistic at all.
The he'll play the kind of role that
you'd suggest.
Yeah.
So the way we've demon hope I'm wrong.
I hope you're on too.
I don't know.
But the way we've demonized cops as part
of this.
I agree.
I mean,
I see a lot of times people are just
screaming about how evil cops are and
they're hunting people down in all of
this stuff.
I don't know a ton of cops,
but I knew some in New York and I know a
couple here.
I mean generally they're trying to do
good.
Right.
I mean,
do you have any experience in which
were,
have you ever been pulled over and had
it?
I probably had been pulled over maybe
more than almost anybody.
You know,
I got my driver's license when I was 15
and a half my learner's permit.
And then when I was 16 I was able to
drive by myself and I probably looked
like I was 12 so I got pulled over
probably a hundred times.
And with the exception of one or two
instances,
the encounter was brief and
professional.
Uh,
one time a cop told me to take my head
out of my ass.
That was the first time I got pulled
over by the way.
I was driving and there was a light
behind me and I knew I hadn't done
anything,
anything wrong.
So I just keep going.
The guy pulled over and screamed at me
and he goes,
why don't you pull over?
And I said,
what?
I said to you,
well,
obviously I didn't,
I didn't think I did anything wrong.
And he said,
whenever you see some lights behind you,
you pull over,
get your head out of your ass.
And he was right.
I should've had my head head of I ask,
you know,
um,
uh,
the instances in which cops kill blacks
has declined 75% in the last 45 years
according to the CDC,
while the instances in which cops are
cops kill whites has pretty much flat
lined.
And so it's going down.
It is very,
very,
very rare for the cop to kill anybody,
let alone an unarmed black person of the
965,
um,
uh,
people that were killed by the police,
in 2015,
less than 4% were white cops killing an
unarmed black man.
It is very rare.
By contrast,
400 people were injured by lightning
last year,
but only 250 people were killed.
Black people were killed by police.
So it's very,
very rare.
So how much of this,
I know you talk about fake news and I
want to get to that,
but how much of this is because the
media is complicit in all of this.
So for example,
just this morning,
I think the Oscar nominations were put
out.
I haven't even seen them yet,
but apparently there are more minorities
this time.
I guess there aren't some more Latinos
and a Dev Patel and some more black
people.
And you know,
for the last couple of years there's
been this Oscars so white thing to me,
and I can only speak for myself,
this is like keep your eye is just off
the ball.
You're just paying attention to the
wrong thing where it's nice to have
people nominated for these things,
but they're irrelevant in the scheme of
what's important and what you should be
caring about is education and all that.
Right.
But the media has made such an
importance out of this that it's like
it's getting the black community's eye
off what's actually important,
which would be education and family and
some of the others.
I couldn't agree with you more.
Um,
I have an actor friend and I said,
why is this important to you?
And he said,
because it provides role models and
enhances the self esteem of black
people.
That's what he said.
I say,
are you aware that black boys and black
girls have higher self esteem than white
girls and white boys?
This has been tested for decades.
It's been the case for a long time and
there are very,
very few Asian actors and actresses,
yet,
uh,
Asian Americans,
Japanese Americans,
Chinese Americans and Korean Americans
on a per capita basis make more money
than virtually anybody else in this
country.
So it's utterly irrelevant.
Yeah.
And for us to pay attention to this,
and it's also not true.
If you look at the last 15 years or so,
roughly 10% or so of the nominees for
the major categories have been black
people.
They've been a couple of years where
there has been a shutout.
Uh,
but um,
add it all up.
It's,
it's about parody with population.
Right.
So that's the irony.
It actually within a couple of
percentage points,
it actually has been a party and Jamie
Foxx who got an Oscar for four re,
uh,
said,
in,
uh,
in connection with this Oscar.
So white movement.
He said,
act better,
be better,
raise your game,
don't demand,
don't yell,
don't scream.
Get better,
act better.
You got an Oscar and,
and,
and I think part of the reason he said
that is because it kind of demeans his
Oscar.
Right?
Cause then it means like you're,
you're complaining that the Oscars are
so white.
How did I get one?
I was lucky.
Yeah.
Maybe just,
maybe I was excellent.
Yeah.
So do you think that at times visibility
is important?
So for example,
I had,
I've had jack a Harry on here.
She was the first black woman.
I think she wasn't for best supporting
actress in two to seven,
uh,
around,
I guess it's around 1989 or so at that
time.
Do you think that a certain amount of is
visibility may have been more important
than it is now?
Like,
cause finally a black person did it even
if you don't think that the thing in and
of itself is,
is important?
I don't think so.
I remember some years ago there was an
Olympic,
uh,
blacks,
skier named Debbie.
Debbie Thomas,
I believe was her last name.
And she was the first,
um,
uh,
Black Olympian and in,
in,
in ice skating.
And she was constantly ask,
who are your role models?
Who are your role models?
Who inspired you?
And finally to me,
out of,
out of exasperation,
she said,
I don't need to see somebody black do
something before I think I can do it.
And that's how I feel.
If I want to do something,
uh,
w w what's holding me back from doing it
other than my own insecurities or,
or,
or inadequacies.
Just get up and make it happen.
Yeah.
How exhausting is this conversation to
you?
I don't mean this literal conversation
right now,
but just this thing,
you know,
so much of what you talk about has to
do,
unfortunately be framed around something
that you don't even think is,
is real.
You know what I mean?
It's something that you think should be
put behind us that actually is behind
us.
And yet you have to talk about it a lot.
Just on a personal note,
how does that feel for you?
It doesn't bother me.
I,
I think there's a lot of a feeling that
race and racism remain major problems in
America.
Uh,
and I think that that you're approaching
this with,
with,
with sincerity and,
and,
and since and real concern.
Uh,
I just don't think it's that big of a
deal.
Yeah.
By the way,
I've emailed duray Mckesson [inaudible]
who's the leader?
I think the quasi leader of black lives
matter.
He hasn't responded,
but I will,
I will ask him again.
So I'm not doing it.
I'm not just playing favorites.
I'm just putting that out.
No,
no,
no problem.
Um,
this is America.
There.
There are Cubans who are braving shark
infested waters to get here.
There are people from Central America
coming up here.
Why do people come here?
Why does so many people want to come to
America and is because it is the land of
the free and the home of the brave.
It is a place where you can go from
nothing to something a faster than it
anytime,
anywhere in all of human history.
That's why we're here and to me again,
you are are almost giving the fourth
finger to all the people fought,
struggled,
worked hard and died for people to sit
around in 2017 in Bitch Moan and whine
about race and racism.
Yeah.
I suspect I know your answer to this,
but what do you make of all these people
that now want to look back on history
and label everyone racist from back
then?
You know I was at Monte Cello,
which was Thomas Jefferson's home,
Thomas Jefferson who owned slaves who
was sleeping with at least one sleep,
I think several who they,
by the way at Monte Cello,
I took the tour.
There's only about a year and a half
ago,
they fully owned up to everything.
They did not.
I thought it was incredible what they
did.
They said this man was writing the laws
to free the slaves at the same time he
was sleeping with the slaves,
which I think you could probably make an
argument was rape in a certain respect
because they weren't equals right now
I'm not saying he's a rapist in the
conventional sense,
but you can.
I can see that argument being made,
but what about that concept that we're
going to look back at?
What the,
I think the left is now trying to do is
look at all of our founding fathers and
take them out of the give our 2017
morality to them who lived very complex
lives.
I mean without Thomas Jefferson,
the slaves do not get fried as quickly
as they did.
Well.
I think the idea of going back and
airbrushing history and looking at
history through the,
through the filter of today's a morality
is pretty silly.
I think all a state can be.
It's just in its own time.
And that's what we're trying to be
trying to do right now.
Uh,
and people are right to call a slavery
Americans,
America's original sin.
But without a compromise,
you wouldn't have had an America.
And,
um,
and there was 750,000
people,
both sides who died in order to free the
slaves.
And people don't really have an
understanding of,
of,
of the,
the,
the scale of the sacrifice that people
made.
750,000
people at a time when this country was
just 10% the size of what it is.
So that's like 7.5
million people dying,
uh,
in order for there to be an outcome with
slaves are freed and that's the,
and are the people that died and not the
ones who've been injured.
It was a horrific thing,
uh,
that,
that America went through.
Uh,
and,
and on the other side comes the 13th
amendment,
the 14th Amendment,
the 15th Amendment,
uh,
the civil rights movement and,
and all the things that have happened
since then,
but that,
this was a country they went to war over
this proposition.
Yeah.
What,
what do you make of this intersectional
thing that we have going on now?
And I think we saw a lot of it at the
woman's March,
this,
this past weekend where there's a
certain amount of people that are trying
to conflate trans issues with black
issues and then Muslim issues with
women's issues.
And just this whole thing where,
you know,
I talk about all the time this
oppression Olympics and now we're all,
they're all tied together by this
oppression,
but they all have to kind of beat each
other and oppression to be the winner.
This is a toxic mess,
Huh?
It is.
It's,
it's a,
it's what I call the victim correct
culture where everybody has a grievance,
uh,
and everybody's making a demand on the
government to solve that grievance,
uh,
when in fact,
we have far more in common than we have
apart and we ought to celebrate our
similarities and we're not doing that.
Okay.
So let's move to trump then.
I think what you said,
there's an interesting segway to trump.
So there seems to be this feeling that
the white supremacist back,
they're back in business.
And it should be,
and it's because of trump.
So I saw this.
Do you see this video of this Guy
Richard Spencer,
who's The alt right guy and you got to
get in hunched?
He got punched.
I tweeted out that I,
this guy has obviously bad ideas.
I've had family members on both sides of
my family killed in the Holocaust.
So I am not a Nazi sympathizer in any
way,
but I have to defend his right to free
speech without being punched because
that's the whole point.
You can't just defend it when it's easy.
You got to defend it when you don't want
to.
And that's,
but I saw a lot of people on the left,
a lot of famous people,
a lot of people with a lot of
influencing.
No,
it's okay to punch Nazis,
which if you just follow their logic
through,
well he could have killed him cause you
could accidentally kill somebody.
And then if it's okay to punch a random
person because of their beliefs,
can we blow up his car?
Can we bombed his house?
I mean this is a,
this is a horrifically slippery slope,
right?
Oh,
of course it is.
Uh,
is it okay for me to,
to,
to burn up a building,
uh,
because I'm unhappy with,
because of the way the police treat me
are riots perfectly.
Okay.
Uh,
would it be okay if somebody walked up
to John Lewis and punched him because
they feel that John Lewis should have
attended the Donald Trump inaugural?
Where do we,
where do we go with this?
Are you kidding me?
Yeah.
And,
and believe me,
it would have been a huge story if that
had been somebody like John Lewis who
had been punched as opposed to this
Spencer Guy,
uh,
that the media doesn't care about.
Uh,
and feels is loathsome.
I understand that,
but I would've thought that would've
been a little more coverage of it,
but there wasn't very much.
Yeah.
So I know a certain amount of people are
gonna Watch this and go,
wait a minute,
wait a minute.
Here's a black guy and a Jew somehow
defending a Nazis,
right to free speech.
He wants to,
I'm pretty sure he'd want to kick both
of us out of the country or something
close to that.
But it's tough to have principles,
right?
I mean it isn't that,
isn't that the crux of what you're
saying?
Basically the through line of all of
this is you got to have some principles,
wasn't it voltaire who said,
I guess we have what you've said,
but I would defend to my death your
right to say it.
I mean we're talking about principles
here.
Yeah,
free speech.
So,
and by the way,
it's not unlawful to it to hate
somebody.
You can hate somebody.
As you pointed out earlier,
you can't put your hand on that person,
but you have every right to dislike
somebody for whatever reason you want.
Yeah.
So I sense that a lot of people think
though that white supremacy is back,
that they,
that they feel that there was a link to
trump somehow.
I don't really see that link.
But there there was a link that somehow
he unearthed this and now pepe the frog
and Rob Bay,
the monkey and the white supremacists,
they've been unearthed and now they feel
it's okay.
So their only response is to hit back.
I would argue,
which I think you would argue,
which is your beat them with better
ideas.
Let this 80th talk and guess what he's
going to show what a fraudulent bigot he
actually is.
Right.
Um,
but do you think there's any resurgence
of actual white supremacy?
I mean,
is that a real issue?
I'm not saying it.
Uh,
Donald Trump got a higher percentage of
the black vote.
They,
Mitt Romney did and John Mccain did.
He got a higher percentage of the
Hispanic vote than Mitt Romney did.
Um,
he got a smaller percentage of the white
vote,
then his,
um,
his predecessor,
then the,
the,
the Republican rand beforehand.
So I'm not seeing it.
I am seeing a resurgence in the,
uh,
assertion that white supremacy is back,
but I'm not seeing it.
Look,
um,
one of Donald Trump's,
a surrogate's was doctor Ben Carson is
doctor Ben Carson.
Uh,
somebody that's going to cozy up to
somebody who is a white supremacist.
Uh,
one of my friends,
Steven Miller,
uh,
is the young,
speech writer who wrote Donald Trump's
inaugural speech and wrote his rnc
speech.
He's about 30 in his early thirties.
I've known him since he was a teenager.
He is not a,
somebody is going to work for it for a
white supremacy.
He happens to be a Jew.
Um,
so donald trump's a wrong vehicle to peg
that on.
And John Lewis said that he was not
going to attend his,
his inauguration the first time in all
of his years being in Congress.
He's not going to to attend the
presidential inauguration.
False.
If he,
he,
he did not attend George W Bush's
inauguration.
Now with George W.
Bush a Nazi.
What's he,
what's he a fascist?
Was he a racist?
What was your argument?
Mr.
Lewis,
if he were here,
I'd ask him for not attending George W
Bush's inauguration.
I understand donald trump's,
but explaining George W.
Bush to me.
Right.
So is that the crazy position that a lot
of people have painted themselves into
now they've screamed and ranted and
raved that trump and this whole movement
is,
is vial and racist and all this stuff.
We're now,
if he does any good,
they're going to have to lash out in
crazy ways because you can't have a guy
that you've been calling Hitler for a
year.
Suddenly you can't suddenly admit that
he's doing some good stuff,
right?
So they've put themselves in a really
tight intellectual box here.
I think they have,
and again,
Donald Trump is a bad vehicle,
uh,
to,
to do that with because if you look at
some of his points of view,
they are quite populous and quite left
wing.
He and Bernie Sanders were completing
each other's sentences on free trade.
And when a Donald Trump had the
interview with 60 minutes and he was
asked about same sex marriage,
he said it was settled law.
He could have said the same thing he
said about abortion,
which was I'm going to put on a justice
who ultimately would turn over Roe v
Wade.
He didn't say that,
but that's really what,
what,
what he wants to happen.
But he could have said that regarding
gay marriage because,
uh,
gay marriage is less settled law then
abortion.
Uh,
abortion has been on the books since
1973.
The gay marriage decision just now came
down.
Oh,
so your argument is that he's actually
more for gay marriage than he is for
abortion on gay marriage.
He said to Steve Croft,
that issue has been settled.
Really he could have said,
I'm going to put on justices that,
that,
that we'll look at the constitution and
we'll have all these issues.
Go back to the state like abortion.
But he didn't,
he said same sex marriage is settled
law,
which was his way,
in my opinion,
of signaling to all of the people in the
country,
especially his critics that I am okay
with same sex marriage.
And on,
as I mentioned,
on and on,
on free trade,
he and Bernie Sanders were,
were,
were identical and on infrastructure.
He wants a trillion dollar
infrastructure,
uh,
investment.
Uh,
Chuck Schumer just now said that he's
okay with that.
Yeah.
When you have chuck Schumer smiling,
it seems to me you ought to be worried.
But the point is,
these are the kinds of things,
and they felt that Obama's stimulus was
too small and this is bigger than that.
So they're,
they're giddy over all over all of that.
So why Donald Trump is engendering all
of this hostility when he has so many a
centrist,
if not leveling point of view is beyond
me.
Well,
I think it has to do is just the way he
speaks.
I think you know,
my concern about him from day one,
as I've said a thousand times in that
year,
I don't know what his moral center is,
but I don't know that,
you know what a lot of these guys,
moral center is at the end of the day,
a lot of them speak a lot clearer.
So you to,
you think you know it,
right?
And then you don't know it.
You'd probably argue that about Obama,
but for trump,
I don't know what it is.
That being said,
I think the answer to your question is I
think the left no longer has the ability
to understand the difference between
words and actions.
So they see his gruff language and some
poorly phrase things and that he speaks
not that well,
and then they think that translates into
action when in fact he actually did a
lot of things that brought them more
center.
I think it goes back to what we said
earlier and there's just a lack of
critical thinking.
I think we are at the end of your name.
Uh,
all of a sudden there are certain sets
of,
of views that people assume you have a
and they,
they go after those views.
Um,
I look at his,
his,
his moral center.
I look at Donald Trump's family.
Uh,
these kids adore him.
He's had three different marriages.
It's complicated to pull all that stuff
together.
Three different marriages,
uh,
children from all three of the marriages
and they all get along and they all
worked up their father.
How bad a guy can he be?
You know,
it's funny,
I had Donald Trump jr on my Sirius xm
show talking about how he was for gay
marriage is about a little bit before it
got passed it about let's say three
years ago,
four years ago.
I'm talking about how he personally was
for gay marriage,
even though his dad was in it and that
his dad said,
you go out and tell people whatever you
want.
So I thought that that's actually a nice
marker of,
of sort of what a father should be.
Do you his authoritarian side at all
because as you said,
small l libertarian,
so you want the government to scale
back.
I sense he is going,
he,
yeah,
he's going to lower taxes and they were
already doing some stuff with
regulations that you're probably four
and that kind of stuff,
but do you sense there could be an
authoritarian side even controlling what
businesses can do overseas and that kind
of stuff that you may not like?
There are.
There are things he said that I don't
like.
Uh,
I don't know that I would label them
authoritarian.
I would label them as stupid.
For example,
saying I'm going to put on a 30 or 40%
tariff on goods that come in for this
country.
If you've left the country and started a
factory,
all you're doing is discriminating
against cheap prices and hurting
American consumers.
I as a business person have an
obligation to maximize shareholder
return.
And if my biggest cost is labor and I
can go somewhere else and build my
widgets,
uh,
for less money,
I have an obligation to do that.
And if I don't do that,
my competitor will.
And for a business person like Donald
Trump to tell another business person,
I'm going to punish you for it,
for seeking profits to me is outrageous.
I understand and support his idea that a
lot of the reason people go overseas
because we have onerous regulations and
high corporate tax.
Once you lower the regulations and lower
the corporate taxation,
and I had a CEO had made a calculation
that I can make more money by putting my
factory I in a third world country.
How dare you tax me for,
for doing that.
We'll get you the right to do that.
Right.
So you would basically argue that if you
lowered the corporate tax rates,
did everything he could to unregulate
business here,
you wouldn't need that tax on the
overseas stuff because it would be
humming and pairing nicely here.
You wouldn't,
you wouldn't need to leave the country
to set up a factory because you would
stay here.
What we have right now are all these
environmental rules and regulations
designed to fight climate change.
We have a very high corporate tax rate,
the highest in the industrialized world.
Uh,
you deal with those kinds of things and
you'll take away the incentive that some
ceos have a to move outside of the
country.
But so when you take all those away and
you lower the lower the,
uh,
the regulatory burdens that ceos have to
deal with and they still want to put a
factory somewhere,
you have absolutely no right to stop
them from doing that,
in my opinion.
Do you think it's hilarious how we look
at certain companies that do the exact
same things as other companies?
Some are.
Okay.
So for example,
trump made his ties in Mexico,
which I kept saying all along,
this isn't something you're getting him
on.
He,
you're,
he's proving the point.
He's proving the point that it's cheaper
to do there,
change the regulations and then he
wouldn't have to at the same time a
company and trump was mocked
relentlessly for doing that.
Right.
At the same time,
apple designs their stuff in Cupertino
as they say,
and it's all made in China and they hide
all kinds of stuff tax wise.
But we're all walking around with
iphones.
How come some companies are able to,
that's just the cool factor of apple.
I think so.
And uh,
I think Al Gore was on the board of
directors of apple at one point or if he
isn't now,
uh,
and here they are manufacturing stuff in
China.
Um,
yeah.
Some companies have better pr than other
companies.
He also sold current TV,
Al Jazeera,
which is owned by Cutera,
one of the biggest exporters of oil in
the world.
But,
but that's not what we digress.
Let's not dwell on that.
Um,
okay,
let's,
let's move over to fake news because I,
this is so tied into what's happening
with trump,
the outrage machine and then the fake
news machine.
All of this,
you've been all over this.
I am just a pocket,
a pap apoplectic and apoplectic about
what's going on with this.
Because I see the mainstream media
crumbling.
I see online media growing,
but I see risks in that too because
anybody can put on a tie and pretend
they're somebody and get a desk and
that's,
you know,
it is what it is.
Uh,
how bad is this scorge of fake news?
I think we've always had really bad fake
news.
It just got passed off as CBS,
NBC or ABC.
Um,
uh,
there've been lots of stories in my
opinion that had been fake news.
Stories are,
one of them was,
um,
uh,
when Obama was pushing obamacare,
he said over and over again,
uh,
that his mother who was suffering from
cancer as she lay dying in her hospital
bed in Hawaii,
had to fight with her insurance carrier
to pay for her medical bills and her
hospital bills.
Turns out it is not true.
He said it over and over and over again.
A book came out by a woman named Janice
Scott,
who used to work with the New York
Times.
Therefore it must be a good book.
And she said that those bills were
promptly paid.
The only coral was that Obama's mom and
dad had taken out a,
um,
uh,
a policy,
so that if she got sick,
she would be entitled to money.
And the,
the law is that if you are,
have been diagnosed you and you try to
take our policy like that,
uh,
we can,
we can challenge it.
And that's what they challenged.
But regarding her medical bills,
hospital bills,
they were paid promptly,
but he said it over and over and over
again.
And it helped to drive the narrative
that if my more that got jacked over and
she has a phd and has a son from Harvard
with a law degree,
imagine what these insurance carriers
will do to you.
It turns out complete completely not
true.
Another fake news.
Oh,
I said,
I think I said earlier when Obama said
during his many pref press conferences,
I am most proud of the fact that I
rescue the economy.
Really tarp was done by George W.
Bush.
The bailouts were done by George W.
Uh,
and many of the things that Obama has
done,
including stimulus,
actually hurt the recovery,
didn't help it,
it,
he says this over and over again with a
straight face.
And the failure of the media not to ask
challenging questions when he raises
that to me is fake news.
So that's the issue.
So not to split hairs there,
but that's the issue that we've had
basically a lapdog media.
So there's the idea,
I think when the left talks about fake
news,
they're talking about these right wing
sites that are just making up things,
right?
They push a lot of that on,
on Breitbart and we can talk about that
you want,
but that's different than what you're
talking about,
which is just immediate.
That just simply got cozy.
They got cozy with the people in power,
so they just stopped doing their job.
You're calling that fake news.
Absolutely.
These are two separate types of fake.
I talked earlier about Obama pulling
completely out of Iraq over the
objection of his,
uh,
of his team.
He also then said,
well,
the reason I did that is because George
W.
Bush had negotiated a,
an agreement that required me to leave.
At the time,
I did completely not true.
George W.
Bush negotiated an agreement,
but he fully expected his successor to
negotiate a stay behind force.
And again,
Obama has said this over and over again,
and the media hasn't said anything about
that.
That to me,
fake news.
Right.
So I remember when that happened and I
remember thinking when Obama said it,
yes,
they had,
they had set the date,
but obviously Obama had plenty of
political capitol at the time.
If he had wanted to stay,
he could've stayed.
So that's right.
This is just a,
it's just a conflation of poor media
practices and we saw a lot of this with
Hillary.
I just pour media practices,
the willpower,
the willingness to,
the willingness to look the other way
because it's a guy that you're pulling
for.
Yeah.
When Obama came into office,
he reneged on a deal that George W.
Bush and negotiated.
He negotiated a deal with Poland and the
Czech Republic to for them to get
missile defense.
Russia didn't like it.
Obama thought that he could curry favor
with Russia by reneging on the deal.
And he did,
um,
the failure of the media to bring this
up and to bring up him saying him and
pushing the reset button and him saying
to Medvedev,
ah,
when I get reelected I have more,
I'll have more flexibility.
The failure of the media to bring this
up when they're hitting Donald Trump for
being too cozy with Putin is another
example of fake news.
So that to me is the monster that we've
created.
They did nothing for so long now because
they don't like trump.
They're trying to be professionals,
which I want them to write.
I want them to do true investigative
journalism.
I want them to fight the power.
But they seem almost ridiculous doing it
now because they're watching tweets and
getting outraged before weekend.
Right.
I just wrote a column about all of this
and what I've said is that the media has
rediscovered their mission now that the
Republicans back in the White House.
But before that,
in my opinion,
they didn't do their jobs.
Yeah.
Easy.
Almost too late for them.
Have they?
Because I think they've lost so much
credit that even now is they scurry to
get their credit back.
I mean,
for example,
uh,
yesterday,
the day before I watched the second Sean
Spicer,
uh,
press conference,
not,
not the quick one where he was bickering
about the first official.
I watched the first official one,
right?
I think it was Monday and I watched the
entire thing.
I'm doing cardio or that's the only way
I can watch it.
Right.
I got to buy up to be moving.
You got to run from the bullshit.
So I'm watching this thing.
Okay.
I thought he basically did a pretty
decent job.
He took a good Julian questions.
He answered them in pretty much the same
way that all prices people do,
which is,
you know,
half answers and partially that's what
they do.
But suddenly I saw the headlines.
First of off the,
the main twitter moment headline was
saying that he was focusing on the
numbers of people there.
That was just a small portion and it was
only because they kept asking him that
same question.
Right?
So that's also fake news,
right?
Where they just keep framing something a
certain way,
not just the,
not just what it said,
but that you can take an hour and a half
thing and go,
well,
this was the part that was important
when,
you know,
it actually wasn't the part that,
let me say a couple of things about that
spicer and not only quarreled with the
idea that trump's a audience was larger
than what the media report it.
Uh,
he also talked about the fact that a
reporter from Time magazine,
not,
not the Bug Tussle Gazette Time magazine
said that I'm a Donald Trump removed the
bus to vml k from the Oval Office.
Now that to me is a major story.
If it were true,
it is not true.
Time magazine,
uh,
reported for twice Time magazine tweeted
it and it went around the world rather
than focus on that fake news part,
they talk about what Sean Spicer said
about the crowd size because that's
something they could probably make an
argument about.
What the mlk thing,
they can't make an argument about it.
So when we haven't even talked about
that and we found out because of Wiki
leaks.
David,
how many of these reporters,
we're in bed with the DNC in bed with
Hillary,
I mean in New York Times reporter is
doing a massive story on,
on Hillary and and gave her veto proof
over quotes.
She doesn't like a power that she,
that she in fact use and took out a
quote that she had made about Sarah
Pailin.
Yeah.
You're not making this up by the night
wash it.
Washington Post,
uh,
was doing a story on John Podesta and
found out some conflict of interest
regarding money and gave him a heads up
and told him,
don't worry about it.
We'll bury it in the,
in the,
in the story a staffer is far for jake
tapper in for Wolf Blitzer of CNN,
contacted the DNC and said,
we're about ready to interview some
Republicans.
You have any questions for us?
Dana Milbank is a columnist with the
Washington Post.
He did a story,
a column called the 10 most outrageous
things Donald Trump has ever said.
He contacted the DNC and said,
I'm about ready to do this column on the
10 most outrageous things Donald Trump
ever said.
Do you have any suggestions?
They gave him 10 suggestions.
He used eight.
Yeah.
Are you kidding me?
You didn't even mention the most
egregious one in my opinion,
which is the whole Donna Brazil thing,
which is to me the heart,
because that one is the heart of how
corrupt media and politicians have
become.
But at least cnn fired her.
But the d DNC hired her as interim chair
even after she was out in his head as
having conspired with hilary to make
sure that Bernie Sanders,
uh,
got,
didn't,
did not win.
So what is at the moment,
but I think the most are one of the most
outrageous ones is,
um,
a guy named Kurt.
I can wald.
Yeah.
He writes for Newsweek and tweeted that
Donald Trump had been put in a mental
institution for some time,
no evidence for it whatsoever.
He took the tweet down pretty quickly
when it was debunked but he wasn't fired
or or even suspend or even chastise.
So this is where people talk about post
truth.
Now I know we don't want to be in a post
truth society what's post true,
but we'll post truth that at this point,
you know any idiot who's amass the
150,000
twitter followers,
it has as much influence in a lot of
respects as news one on one was that
150,000
acre?
Thank you for calling me an idiot.
I just went above it.
That's why I mentioned that number cause
I was any idiot that could have as much
influence but,
but really you could have a set,
you could figure out how to do the
social media game and somehow because of
that you've got a little blue check to
now.
Now you're an authority on this stuff
and there so that I do see as a major
risk that while I wanted the mainstream
media to get the lashing,
it deserved the fact that it's now
everyone's just picking their truth
wherever they can find it.
As a huge problem.
It's,
it's both a problem and a blessing.
It also means that the,
uh,
the,
the traditional establishment media,
it can be,
can be gone around.
Uh,
you can get your ideas out,
uh,
and uh,
and nothing can stop you from
communicating to people.
Uh,
but you're right.
It means that anybody can communicate
and whether or not he or she is
credible,
uh,
is left to you as a consumer to figure
out.
Is there any way that you think trump
can reconcile this relationship with the
media?
Because I think it's almost the most
important thing right now.
More important than the policies because
it's one thing to just rail against the
media all the time.
Again,
I don't like what the media,
the mainstream media has done,
but do you think you can get to a point
where he'll actually do some real sit
downs,
do some real press conferences and not
do the same things,
you know,
be willing to sit down with an
interviewer.
Hopefully it will be me,
but maybe it will be somebody else and
not demand the questions in advance,
you know,
be better than all the reasons that you
just said the Democrats.
Well,
I don't think it donald trump's job to,
uh,
to curry favor with the media.
I think it's the media's job to be fair.
Um,
and as far as I'm concerned,
he has very little risk.
Um,
he is disliked more than Reagan,
more than George W.
Bush.
Uh,
in my opinion,
uh,
they're out to get him.
And for him to have a more
confrontational attitude towards the
media to me,
makes perfect sense because there is no
upside in him doing it any other way.
They're going to go after him like
nobody's business.
They just,
they just like him because of his
attitude about,
uh,
about,
immigration.
Uh,
they think of him as a racist.
You think of him as a,
as a,
as a bigot,
as a tyrant.
If that's your attitude and you're not
going to cut me any slack,
why should I kiss your butt?
And so I have no problem with what Sean
did.
Sean Spicer,
his first,
uh,
informal press conference when he,
when he blasted the media the way he
did.
And it does turn out that Donald Trump's
audience,
which is the word he used,
uh,
to watch the inaugural with,
was bigger than any audience and history
in part because of social media.
Right?
So a lot of people on twitter were angry
me over that,
cause I didn't say anything about it.
But if you listen to actually what he
said,
he said,
audience,
meaning he,
and then he clarified it on Monday.
He said,
I mean,
people that are streaming it on facebook
and watching on ipads and youtube and
all that,
but everybody wants everyone to get
outraged all the time.
It's exhausting,
isn't it?
It also turns out,
apparently,
that when you look at the,
the,
uh,
the pictures of,
of,
uh,
Obama's inaugural and trump's,
trump's does look thinner,
but my understanding is part of that is
because of security measures.
There are certain places you can't stand
anymore for in place.
You can't go through anymore.
It's a lot of people couldn't get to the
main area because of all these security
requirements.
So you're comparing,
uh,
not apples to apples and so you'd agree
all of that is just sideshow nonsense,
right?
Like it's actually completely
irrelevant.
The amount of people I'm talking about,
not,
not the lying about it,
but just whether they were x amount of
people or why it's completely irrelevant
except that he's putting media on notice
that you have to be fair to me.
Yeah.
Do you think the media regrets,
you know,
it's hard to categorize all the media,
but when they look back at the way they
treated mccain,
who now looks like the most moderate,
the public and of all time,
you know,
and they,
they,
they were times calling him racist.
And I think he has an adopted black
daughter,
if I'm not mistaken.
Or when they look at Romney and the
binders of women and made it sound like
he hates women,
that they,
in a way,
they created trump because any
republican was going to get the cries of
racism,
was going to get the cries of misogyny
and the crisis xenophobia and homophobia
and all that.
Right?
So he brings up Peter Teal.
These still hates gays.
He has a,
uh,
Ben Carson,
he's still lays black.
So in a way,
he was the only answer to this absurd
equation,
right?
I think you're right.
I think the media did they help to
create Donald Trump.
People resent the idea that the media
has gone after Republicans in a way that
they not gone after Democrats.
And so there's a distrust.
And when Donald Trump talked about
political correctness and how he was no
longer going to be politically correct,
a lot of people took that to mean I'm no
longer going to going to thinking of
myself as a racist,
as a sexist,
simply because I've got normal views and
normal ideas at any other guy has.
And I think Donald Trump has given
people like that a certain amount of,
uh,
of comfort and credibility.
Yeah.
All right.
So one more for Ya,
which we'll sort of wrap this whole
thing up.
What happens over the next four years?
Where do you really see this all going?
Do you see this endless clash between,
between trump and the left?
Is there a way to get the media
straightened out?
Can we get some of this societal stuff
to,
to shake out or is it just going to be
more battling because it seems,
I thought there was going to be a couple
of days after the election where
everyone would take a breath.
Right?
It seems like everyone's just ramping up
more and more now.
No,
people see things differently.
We disagree.
We disagree about abortion.
We disagree about same sex marriage.
We disagree about taxes,
about spending,
about foreign policy.
As long as we have those disagreements,
we're going to have these kinds of
disputes.
But I think what will happen,
uh,
hopefully,
is that we have 4% GDP growth.
Uh,
like we did under Ronald Reagan.
Ronald Reagan was overwhelmingly
reelected,
not because people agreed with him,
they disagreed with him about his
nuclear proliferation.
They disagreed about,
uh,
his,
um,
uh,
going into South America and trying to
roll back some of the communists
movements there.
If you go down and list by list,
it was a article in the New York Times
in 1986 I talked about all of these
points of views and how Americans
disagreed with Ronald Reagan,
but they respected him and
overwhelmingly reelected him because
ultimately it comes down to the economy
comes down to pocket book and 70% of the
American people felt that we were on the
wrong track economically.
Uh,
and that is the primary reason in my
view,
why Donald Trump won worst economic
recovery since 1949.
This has been a 2% recovery.
The average recovery 3%.
And the difference between 2% and 3% is
1 million jobs times at length the
recovery.
So if Obama had done nothing had on is
putting,
we have 7 million more jobs than we have
right now.
Yeah.
Well,
he did work on the buddy know we'd have
10 million.
Morgan.
Good.
All right.
Well,
Larry was a pleasure.
We're going to do a little boat to
segment for our audience and I thank you
for coming back.
Pleasure and we're going to link to the
original one and people can see if maybe
I changed you in some ways too.
Who knows?
Well,
I felt I felt the same way leaving as I
felt coming.
How's that?
Fair enough.
All for war on Larry.
Checkout his website,
Larry elder.com.